I'm just saying that if a hot chick came
up and farted in my face I don't know if
I would be like I'm gonna get a lawyer
different different yeah the difference
yeah and different they're a little
different but you know so interesting if
a uh a woman that wasn't attractive did
it I'm just thinking what if I would be
upset so what's what's that all about
right what if Magic Mike had done it to
Krista
Channing Tatum right Channing did it she
would be like yeah what's up dude yeah
no you know or she's like you know what
they do they laugh
he's so funny right because I'm a fat
asian guy oh my God racism no listen
this is racism it's racism
that's what it is racism because that's
where a stone a Salvation hit the answer
yeah I wish I was better looking I can
fart in people's no reason you're fine
you're good